[Music]
hey you guys it's tuesday yeah
i'm still [ __ ] tired i mean even
though
i slept the right where's she going okay
running around she was behind my chair
and i was like afraid to back up
part of it's part of the weather
yeah
it is kind of like very muggy and humid
stuff kind of in between
it's not too bad like i went out for a
walk this morning about 7 15 or
something like that and it was
it's yucky but it's not yeah we're just
sick that's bad we're just sick of it
you know just ready ready for the ready
for it to start cooling down so we can
actually go out and [ __ ] without feeling
like just in dagobah and [ __ ] swamp
yeah goes on for like
three months out of the year four months
out of the year it's pretty bad longer
than that yeah i can i can handle it hot
it's just not when it's
[ __ ] super hot yeah yeah like i said
like when you open the door and it's
like
walking into like a wet oven or
something like that it's like like a
blanket the soup the super super hot of
it is really only two and a half months
maybe three months
the rest of it
it's kind of hot i don't know it's
always too hot for me
she likes cool weather i like it's kind
of hot but i would like it if it was
just like cool to cold all the time as
soon as it starts getting in the 80s i'm
okay with it i just don't like it in the
90s
say yeah nineties are the hundreds it's
not looking bad 99 humidity
yeah beowulf was saying something about
the kukulkan you haven't had you haven't
had that drink on the show in a long
time yeah
i put it we put it in the cookbook yeah
but uh you know it's pretty easy to make
but i kind of figured i had to take a
break from uh i had to break up with
tequila for a while
[Laughter]
drinking too much tequila we've been
yeah it's expensive too it is here here
in the us it's good the good shit's
expensive we've been doing mostly vodka
yeah and honestly we just want like
cheaper flavored vodkas yeah they're
chicken stuff cheap easy to mix and
they're [ __ ] effective cheap and
effective and they go with everything
they go with everything which is nice
which like i said that's kind of why i
like it comes in a big old plastic
bottle beautiful well that's good
because then if i'm clumsy and i drop it
then it won't break pinnacle cake and
pinnacle whipped cream those are the two
main ones yeah like i said they go with
everything yeah louis says it was 96
here yesterday yeah i think it was it
says it says it's 90 degrees right now
mostly cloudy
that's what it says on my thing when
it's in the low 80s and it's gonna start
getting into the low 80s in a couple
weeks and when it starts getting into
that then i don't i don't give a [ __ ] as
much 70s is easy
i kind of ladies and gentlemen i kind of
wish it was in the 50s and below all the
time right i don't even know if there's
anywhere on earth where it's in the 50s
and below it's not like antarctica or
something like that i don't want to
freeze my balls off either i just don't
you know
i just i just like it like in the 50s or
below
it's it's like between 80 and 83 for a
long time here yeah that goes on for
quite a while true
but that's not that bad i can deal with
it
yeah well if you have air conditioning
it's nice yeah
even outside you know i can wear a
motorcycle armor and ride at that it's
not a big deal yeah
um when it says when it's in the 70s
it's nice real nice
all right so you guys had been i had
several people like uh recommend this
movie to me and i just like and i kept
putting it off i didn't realize it was
it was that old i didn't realize it was
from 2011 but um i
had it on my list for like a really long
time and then finally last night i was
like okay [ __ ] finally i'm gonna sit
down and watch this i think it was on
amazon prime uh might have been i think
louis recommended it and i think
somebody else did as well and i've seen
it on a couple other lists this is the
2011 movie take shelter starring the
awesome michael shannon how can you not
[ __ ] love michael shannon he [ __ ]
rules
we just saw that thing the other day uh
elvis and nixon right that he yeah where
he made it
he does actually doesn't look anything
like elvis but he he pulled it off he
captured the
essence of elvis yeah the cool thing
about michael shannon is that captured
the elvis when elvis isn't working yeah
that's it that's that's that's what was
good about it what's cool thing about
him
uh the cool thing about him is that he's
this big hulking
dude and he's like he's really good at
playing
parts where
um i kind of would say that he's got
like a simmering craziness like under
there but he can also but he's real good
and this comes across in this one as
well
um where
you were you totally buy that he maybe
is losing his mind but then maybe not
like he's very taciturn
uh but you can see like in his eyes or
like little
you know facial expressions and stuff
like that that he's maybe like losing
his [ __ ] and it's just like he's really
really good at conveying that it's funny
we were talking about that [ __ ]
bonkers ass [ __ ] christian movie that
had like an old bill paxton in it
frailty frailty we were talking about
frailty and this movie kind of reminded
me a lot of frailty
it does a bit and actually the more i
thought about it it's like this movie
man this was really good i mean there
was just something like
there's something it's it's very very
slow but there's something like hypnotic
or like mesmerizing about it
yeah you know what i mean so well at
least well that's kind of how i got to
it like uh khan says don't spoil it i
won't
um but i will say that this is
essentially and i didn't realize this
until because i was thinking about it
when i woke up this morning
this is essentially uh
a noah story basically is basically what
it is it it had it it kind of
it's not a christian movie but it has
kind of a christian tone to it but don't
think of it
as an as in as in [ __ ] orthodox
christianity more like new age
spirituality
psychic abilities that's really i mean
it could be or is it delusion it's it's
it could be read in a lot of different
ways but like the more i thought about
it the more i was like this is
essentially like a modern
working class midwest version of like
the noah story pretty much is what it is
so what you have is like michael shannon
he plays this guy named curtis
and like i said he's like a working
class type dude he works on a
construction site or something like that
makes decent money uh looks like his
wife
doesn't work but she just has kind of
like a you know or she works at home and
she has just kind of like a little side
gig like sewing and embroidering and
stuff and they have a daughter who's
hearing impaired and it looks like their
life is like pretty good
um
but then he starts having these weird
dreams and like weird delusions
and they kind of all or hallucinations i
guess you would call them um they
usually yeah they usually have something
to do with him looking out and seeing
like a really horrible like apocalyptic
storm coming
and then sometimes like when it rains
like it's real like how does he describe
it in the movie he says it's like motor
oil like it's like raining this thick
like maple syrupy kind of rain and he
starts having all these dreams that
people in his life
are attacking him
or like there's one where his like dog
attacks him and he has one like where um
somebody's like trying to kidnap his
daughter it's like so he has like all
these really really horrible upsetting
dreams
um
and they all have to do with like a
storm coming and he starts having this
overwhelming feeling
that something really really really bad
is gonna happen
and so this manifests into him they have
like they live in ohio i guess it's ohio
and um they live kind of on this you
know in a rural kind of community and
they have like an old tornado shelter
like you know a lot of people in the
midwest have uh but it hasn't really
been used so he decides that he's gonna
like build out this shelter
because for this like coming
whatever it is he's not entirely sure
what it is but he knows that it's
something really really bad and it's
like apocalyptic and the interesting
thing about it though is that i think
like i said it's better like not really
like going too much into
what the movie's about because you don't
actually know
because he has a history in his family
of like mental illness like paranoid
schizophrenia um and he maybe thinks
that maybe he's you know starting to
manifest symptoms of that but then again
on the other hand he's also like pretty
sure that like whatever this bad thing
is and he's not sure what it is is gonna
happen
so
it's interesting because then he starts
like you know when he starts building
out this shelter and everything like
that obviously he has to take out this
big loan and they can't really afford it
and you know and all this kind of like
[ __ ] starts happening so it's almost
kind of like it's like a noah story but
it's also like
a self-fulfilling prophecy type of story
because he had a good life at the
beginning but then like when all this
stuff started happening like he almost
started like self-sabotaging you could
read it that way too
or it's like i said it doesn't have to
be necessarily biblical although that's
kind of what i got from it i got like an
apocalyptic because some of the [ __ ]
that he sees um you know with with the
storm clouds and the the birds
especially like a couple times he sees
like these crazy like birds flying in
weird formations and [ __ ] like that so i
definitely got kind of like a biblical
but it's not like super
i don't feel like it's super super up in
your face
that it's biblical because it could be
read
in lots of different ways just any kind
of like apocalyptic
interpreter i think so too he might have
had it he might have had a christian
background so
he's interpreting it as something out of
scripture kind of it's not
i mean you know he's not seeing visions
of angels and jesus or anything but it
it's like the apocalypse is coming
and it's almost kind of like i think he
says too to one of the counselors
because like i said he's he's willing to
entertain the fact that maybe he's just
um you know great going great going
crazy uh but then again he's pretty sure
that [ __ ] maybe [ __ ] is bad [ __ ] is
gonna happen and he needs to like be
prepared for it yeah um but he he i kind
of think that he thinks that when the
rain comes everyone's gonna go crazy
because in his dreams
all the dreams are different but like
he says like the rain kind of makes
people go crazy or makes people attack
him it can be a turn it can be it can be
interpreted in a couple different ways
it's religious or psychic or
instincts it might be animal instincts
that he knows that something's coming
he thinks it's coming
uh it might be a false alarm a lot of
people you just got to see the move
y'all hate you know i hate to [ __ ]
yeah like i said it's not because i feel
like a lot when khan said that he hadn't
uh seen it so don't spoil it um and
somebody just commented i love take
shelter that movie shows what would
happen if a 21st century american were
to become an old testament prophet
basically which yeah it kind of does
have that but like i said it's not super
over the top it didn't actually really
even
i mean i got that it was like some of
this stuff was apocalyptic in the sense
of like biblical apocalypse but it
wasn't real
uh it was it could be interpreted like i
said in lots of different yeah and
you're not really sure i don't think it
was well [ __ ] man i don't want to
[ __ ] ruin it i don't think this is a
is a worldwide apocalypse that he's
foreseeing i think he's seeing a
localized event
that for him and his family will be
apocalyptic that but it's unclear
it's unclear whether the movie ends it's
unclear it's unclear what it is it's
almost kind of like there
could have been more to the story um
you just have to see it you know
my interpretation was is that it was
kind of showing
psychic abilities
that it's difficult to [ __ ] really
put your finger on them they're kind of
a mixture of a lot of things they might
seem to be
religious or they might seem to be in
you know maybe buried instincts within
the human mind too it's a it's a it's
it's it's it's a it's a it's a what do
you call it
it's a phenomenon of the mind
so
difficult to measure what's going on in
the mind you know what i mean yeah it's
just that
he's having visions of something he
thinks coming in the future
and i yeah and and like you said it's
it's great because it could be
interpreted in just like a personal
apocalypse or it could be a worldwide
apocalypse it could totally go either
way
and yeah he's just listening to his
instincts yeah that's what you know
i guess
you guys have to be the judge when you
see it and i mean i love michael shannon
in pretty much everything um you know he
played ku klun ski too didn't he in the
in the iceman yeah you saw that did we
yeah i saw it i don't know i don't
remember a few i thought you saw it too
but i saw it yeah it was great i've seen
it a couple of times actually um
but um it's a good flick um
don't be in a hurry this is not an
action movie
no it's not it's a psychological but
like i said there was something kind of
like i was sort of like mesmerized by it
it's not real challenging to watch you
don't really have to
figure it out that much i mean it's it's
good if you do you don't really
you have you kind of have to pay
attention to it you do
but it's not that difficult i guess yeah
i mean it's a pretty i mean it's a
fairly straightforward story really i
mean she's just having these visions
yeah there were times where i thought it
was kind of slow i'm like come on now
let's get come on let's keep it moving
but that's what the director wanted to
do yeah and this is uh the director's
jeff nichols this was actually his
second movie um he also did one called
mud which a lot of people said was good
and um i can't remember what the other
one was called but uh but yeah this was
only the second one and i think his
first movie was uh had michael shannon
in it too michael shannon like i said i
love him in everything but he is so
great in this just like the passion the
way that he plays this character
is just you can tell that this is a dude
you know he's a midwestern
working class dude he's not one of these
people that's like comfortable talking
about their feelings um and he indeed
that's one of the points of contention
like in the movie that he keeps so much
stuff from his wife like he doesn't tell
her she's played by jessica chastain by
the way
um he doesn't tell her about all these
dreams until like way later on he
doesn't tell her about like a lot of the
stuff that he's doing uh which makes her
really angry justifiably um so he's just
very because he's not sure
he's not sure if what he's seeing is
actually going to happen or what it is
or if he's just going crazy because like
i said he does have a history of like in
his family like his mom
this movie's kind of kind of like one of
these cool art flicks that punches above
its weight this is a low budget movie
but it's great kind of up there with
like vivarium or artist self-defense and
that actor from the what's what's that
actor that was in both of those two
movies he played the blonde guy yeah
yeah
he's
i like him because he's in he chooses to
be in these uh jesse eisenberg jesse
eisenberg he chooses to do these little
projects based upon how good the script
is you still need to see the social
network yeah i want to see it he's doing
the [ __ ] based on how what
of the script all right how good the
script is so eisenberg's flicks are
gonna be pretty good they're gonna be
interesting
well shannon looks like he's doing the
same kind of thing he's choosing the
movie based upon the script not maybe
not so much the paycheck
uh everything i've seen
that guy is is also kind of like
artistic
i liked his [ __ ] elvis versus elvis
and nixon yeah as a [ __ ] masterpiece
and you gotta i mean like i said i'm i'm
always like you know i i don't i don't
begrudge anybody like making some money
i'm not saying that but it's just kind
of like i really like actors who because
you can tell that they're in it because
they love it
for the craft of it um so they don't
necessarily and honestly i think it's
really cool too when
somebody like um i'm trying to i'm
trying to think of um
an actor that somebody like i know this
is out of left field but somebody like
daniel radcliffe who was in all the
harry potter movies when he was a kid
and then with that money he just chooses
to be in like just weird [ __ ] [ __ ] that
he wants to be in you know what i mean
and i think that's great because he's
like well i don't really need the money
anymore um yeah because i made all the
money so it's like now i can just do
[ __ ] i want to do instead of just like
being in some big blockbusters i don't
want to be now nick cage he's going to
be in any movie you [ __ ] pudding
but nick cage knows that and he knows
that you know that yeah that [ __ ] leans
into being in any old thing well and he
knows that
he's now type cast as caging the [ __ ]
out and he doesn't phone it in he's
gonna [ __ ] give you every [ __ ]
thing no matter how shitty that movie is
his alien rip that predator rip-off that
he was in boy that was a piece of [ __ ]
but he did he did his cages yeah on that
[ __ ] like i said he's always worth
watching even at the movies but then
he'll show up in a masterpiece like
mandy yeah or he'll show up for willie's
wonderland
[Laughter]
where he didn't talk didn't say a whole
[ __ ]
and you know what's funny is that he
didn't say word willie's wonderland but
still he caged his way through that
whole [ __ ] thing cage in the [ __ ] but
i love that he wanted to be in that just
specifically because he didn't have a
single line i thought that was like
another guy who's kind of going down
that road is bruce willis bruce willis
now has to be in anything he's in some
shitty [ __ ] sci-fi action flicks
unlike nicholas cage i won't i won't
automatically watch anything with bruce
willis
i mean i like bruce willis he's fine
yeah but his shit's getting bad but i
kind of feel like
for for me to want to watch it still has
to be a good movie whereas if nicolas
cage is in it i'll still watch it even
if it's a shitty movie just because
nicholas cage is off yeah but not bruce
willis bruce willis anytime they need a
white dude to be in space or something
or a white dude to [ __ ] be tough
beyond his years and bald [ __ ]
they're gonna put they'll put his ass in
he goes yeah i'll do it i'll do it he'll
show up he'll do it will you want to see
the movie no no no well because i i kind
of feel like the movies that he would be
in would just be not bad they'd just be
bland
yeah i just kind of feel like they'd be
like kind of cookie cutter he's not he's
not quite at the cigar level not yet
there's still a chance that [ __ ]
bruce willis might show up in a good
movie
you know there is no chance that seagal
will show up in a game yeah i kind of
feel like once you've gotten down to
that level yeah bruce willis could
totally still be like show up in a
recent movie i mean they tried
to get seagal in a good movie the
expendable's four and he turned it down
he didn't want to work around it because
he's afraid they're gonna make fun of it
well they probably would have they would
do it so he will never be in a good
movie again
cigar
expendables four with segal i would see
that [ __ ] five times over just to see
[ __ ] seagull in that hit
you know tom [ __ ] you you're an [ __ ]
yeah well they would probably just spend
i could be i could carry a great movie i
don't need to be in expendables for
you know ah
i'd love to see him in expendables for
and please
[ __ ] no more chuck norris he [ __ ]
wants that [ __ ] to be pg
13 man [ __ ]
yes screw expandables for
chuck's never been fun he's always like
louie asked have i seen midnight special
i have not but it is uh definitely on
the list
um fourth row down said i'll stick my
neck out and say that in the color out
of space i think nicholas cage was
holding back i think he was too a bit uh
he did cage out i liked all the stuff
with the llamas and everything but um
yeah he wasn't like the craziest i've
ever
seen him color out of space didn't quite
work
it wasn't bad
but it wasn't as good as mandy mandy
[ __ ] was banging on all cylinders
that's true i do i d i did like mandy
better than yeah i did i really i really
liked the color out of space but i liked
me yeah it was okay
it was good uh i'd probably have to say
that willy's wonderland was better than
color out of his face
just gonna say uh well maybe i don't
know if i'd go that far well they're two
very very different movies i don't know
it's watchable it's like hard to compare
them like a lot more watchable
although you know that was the same dude
that directed [ __ ] island to dr
moreau which everybody [ __ ] said that
that movie was terrible
there was some i remember when it came
out i liked it it was [ __ ] weird it
had it had our girl in it [ __ ] um
for roosa
her cute [ __ ] cat dances i forgot she
was in that she was the main attraction
did i ever see that [ __ ] movie i kind
of feel like i did but maybe i don't i'm
pretty sure evidently behind the scenes
the people that nobody wanted to work
with that director again and he he that
was his first movie and [ __ ] he
he was real heartbroken about it you
know he kind of lost his career so then
he comes back with color out of space
and it was real good you know it was
it's a real good movie the visuals
for sure i loved like all the [ __ ]
visuals and [ __ ] like that that was a
really cool looking movie it wasn't as
good as mandy but it was good yeah it
was good um i would say it was uh
better than ireland to dr moreau and
even now i didn't think that that one
was bad either
i don't even i don't remember anything
about it was val kilmer in that yeah
okay
yeah i'm pretty sure i saw it i just
don't remember anything about it
um
camp guy said he was funny but i kind of
think jim carrey was overall overrated i
agree um honestly i couldn't really
stand any of jim carrey's comedy uh when
he was when he did serious roles like he
was [ __ ] great in um eternal sunshine
of the spotless mind he was [ __ ]
great in that because he wasn't trying
to be funny he was just trying to be
like a normal person and uh so he was
really good in that but
i don't know that he can't act when he
wants to but he's one of those people
that he's just kind of like uh adam
sandler it's just kind of like most of
the time they just want to be like these
over-the-top like goofballs and it's
just not funny but they can't actually
act when they want to it's just they
choose not to most of the time for
whatever reason i'm not really sure
there's only one adam sandler
movie that is a masterpiece and it's
that uncut gems that's a [ __ ]
masterpiece i loved that great gangster
movie i loved that movie yeah okay
well he was he was in some other good
stuff too he was in uh spanglish was
pretty good um what was that other one i
can't remember that other like kind of
serious one yeah it was an uncut gem
punch drunk glove was good uncut gems
was a masterpiece though it was yeah
it's a masterpiece film yeah i don't
have it i need to buy it i think we saw
it a couple times didn't we yeah that
was the most super that was one of the
most anxiety-inducing movies i've ever
watched
it's about a new york jewish gangster
guy [ __ ] and he's uh and all these
[ __ ] scams he's running and it's
[ __ ] great it had you on the edge of
your seat the [ __ ] [ __ ] he was
doing with other people's money you're
like how the [ __ ] could a dude live with
himself doing that to somebody else's
money betting but making the loans and
[ __ ] lying and this and that and
making bets
on sports games with other people's
money and winning and that's what he did
is his whole thing was to chisel his way
into your pocketbook and win
yeah and uh it's great great always on
the hustle always on the [ __ ] hustle
yeah um there's a bunch of spiritual
symbolism and stuff in it
um trying to think uh
there was something i was going to say
that there was another masterpiece and
then like it was going to offset it with
it with a [ __ ] super flop
oh
pookie pookie picked up the damn minty
with one thing with she got in one hand
she loves those mint things
every now and then like i buy her a
couple more like i just i think in the
last box i think i got six new ones
because beijing likes them too they pick
them up and like rub them all over their
faces it's mint i guess mint and catnip
are like yeah the same plant family so
um yeah it's a solid flick um
it's worth watching
especially you know
for such a low budget movie
yeah i don't really i don't know uh
we're talking about the we're talking
about take shelter now right yeah okay
i'm not actually sure how much this
costs to make and there are actually
surprisingly a lot of visual effects in
this um you know with all the storms and
the birds and stuff like that and it's
actually really well done it couldn't
have cost that much to make i don't
think it did no i'm sure it didn't but
like i said it's the great thing about
it is that it really kind of cultivates
and like you said it is very slow-moving
so don't expect it to be kind of like
this big action-packed pack whatever
but there's something like really
unsettling about it like and i think
that michael shannon's performance like
really
helps that out a lot because you're not
entirely sure and he's not entirely sure
you know are these visions real you know
am i just going crazy and just the way
he conveys it with not a lot of dialogue
uh just through his facial expressions
his eyes and body language and it's just
it comes across like really really well
i don't know if this is a hollywood
movie it's probably the independent film
did you check did you see um i'm pretty
sure it is yeah independent yeah it's
movies like this i think they're
going to be the future of american film
making if it's not a superhero movie
it's going to be something like this
this could very easily be i'm okay with
that yeah
that'll save filmmaking in in in the u.s
there's just two too many shitty well
because there's so many people that yeah
and we've talked about this lots of
times before but now like the technology
to make movies is so cheap yeah that you
know pretty much anybody that really
really really wants to badly can make
one for not a lot of money you need to
come up with a cool concept it's got a
cool story and good
characters and a good script a very
tight edit
and execute this thing for a very short
amount of money but it has to be
visually convincing that's all doesn't
it doesn't have to be a marvel movie or
anything and this movie did it uh like i
said you know it's the story and the
characters that keep people you know
coming back
and buying these things and appreciating
them you know that's what film is about
um there is a and it's not all just
super heavy in dialogue they do show you
a bunch of cool [ __ ] dream sequences
like his dreams the one dream sequence
in particular that i'm thinking of where
all the furniture like floats up that
was so [ __ ] cool yeah
so there is stuff to see it is cinnamon
cinnamon graphic i guess you could say
um
i put it up there with like us like i
was saying that
put it up there with like
art of self defense and and and and uh
vivarium it's that kind of independent
film
yeah i think this this got a theatrical
release but very limited i think it was
just new york and l.a it played okay and
then um but played at some festivals i
think it won some saturn awards which is
usually that's usually like the sci-fi
horror thriller yeah uh you know awards
or whatever so it did like win a bunch
of awards for that i want to point out
too that jessica chastain is great in
this um she's well she's like a great
actress anyway wasn't she in it chapter
two i kind of feel like
she like growing up beverly she looks
like my cousin
looks like my cousin uh catherine
they do look uh they do look quite a bit
of like ginger like that yeah yeah same
kind of face yeah and the little girl in
this was great too the little uh but
yeah so
so yeah like i said this is kind of one
of those just in but there's something
like really i don't know i just liked
the whole vibe of this it was just like
a really
because it had this like pall of dread
over the whole thing because you weren't
actually sure when he was having all
these like freaky
you know these just like deeply
unsettling kind of visions and you
weren't really entirely sure like what
was going on so
you know it's it was just like really
again that like his life's kind of
starts falling apart a little bit but
yeah it's super good like i said it's on
amazon prime yeah yeah i think it's on
amazon prime you can uh watch for free
or i can't remember because i thought it
was or maybe i looked it up on amazon
prime and you had or maybe it's on hulu
i can't remember because i know one of
the i've looked up one of the um looked
it up on one of the streaming services
and you had to pay to rent it but then i
looked it up on another one and you
didn't have to pay to rent it so maybe
it was hulu that it was freon i can't
remember but yeah so definitely check it
out and i'll be like uh checking out
some more of jeff nichols movies because
i looked a little bit into his like
catalog and pretty much all this was his
second movie he's made a couple more
subsequently but um all of his movies
have got like really really good
reviews and they all sound pretty good
and like i said a couple of them have
michael shannon and i'll watch pretty
much anything with him in it uh but yeah
so
that'll do it for today i guess it's
tuesday yeah so that means tomorrow
night is a uh the drunk ass side
sidetrack show
yeah i'm ready so you're ready
he's mentally getting ready for it yeah
that should be fun so yeah come on by
tomorrow evening at 5 00 pm eastern
standard time have drink with us talk
about whatever [ __ ] we end up
talking about and uh we will see you
guys again tomorrow
bye